we have a guest coming on uh who is an
athlete a philanthropist a mom of three
so I mean for any parents out there um
she's also a mentor for girls in sports
and this is a subject very important to
me right now because I'm putting my own
daughters in sports because I know it's
a very important Road for girls and
we've teamed up with do to raise
awareness about body confidence sport
which is a program designed for coaches
to help Foster a positive experience in
sports for young girls so please welcome
without further Ado Kylie
Kelsey I'm so excited to meet you by the
way it's an honor I am so excited to
meet you well thank you I mean obviously
everybody's like cheering your whole
family on right now and more
importantly what you're doing right now
now as a mother of three getting girls
into sports this feels so near and dear
to me as the mother of two young girls
and you actually coach a field hockey
team is it true that like half of girls
will end up maybe even dropping out of
the sport due literally to body
confidence yes uh Dove research shows
that 45% of young girls are quitting
Sports due to low body confidence by Age
which is actually twice as many as boys
the same age and because of that the
program has been put in place called
body confidence Sports and it is a
resource for coaches to help girls make
sure that they're confident in their
abilities and that they stay in sports
I've always heard that girls who play
sports are you know more likely to be in
positive environments that are a
distraction from from some of the more
things we all worry about as moms and
yet here we are with body confidence
issues how do we deal with this so
emphasizing that strength is a positive
thing making sure that you are
respecting your body for what it can do
and not just how it looks now you grew
up playing sports um and as I invest my
daughters in all these Athletics what
should a mom like me who didn't grow up
playing sports how should I go about
this I think it's really important to
give them the opportunity to try it
encourage them positively to stick with
it this makes me feel better about the
approach I've taken like thank
you
now we both wrote down something that
impacted our body confidence personally
to us as teenagers um what was your word
that you wrote down I'm writing mine
down right now and maybe this is just
the the positive person in me but I
wrote thick thighs but I added equal
strength because that was
my I grew up saying I'm not an
athlete and I think I convinced myself
that my body wasn't capable sometimes
you can create a narrative whether it's
about your thighs or about your lack of
capabilities that we get trapped in and
you can't break that cycle and we've got
to break those Cycles cuz we just cannot
stay stuck in now yes and I think as aom
it's our duty to start those
conversations at home but then uh the
people in their lives that are going to
impact them as well are their coaches
their teachers people like that you have
to hope that somewhere along the way
that they have resources like the body
confidence boort that will help them uh
convey the message appropriately to your
girls and help them maintain that
confidence throughout everything that
they do because that's really how sport
translates by the way you couldn't be
more right about that it is their teach
teachers their friends their coaches
everyone around them has such an effect
and I thank dub for really narrowing in
on what we women say to ourselves and do
to ourselves and what we need to see out
there in the world that makes us feel so
good about who we really truly naturally
are
um I just want to say that I absolutely
love your girls' names um and that
Frankie was in the running for for one
of ours um but when you have Frankie
Kelsey my husband didn't set us up for
Success on that
one thank you Kylie Kelsey for
empowering our girls thank you to J
thank you so
[Applause]
much